Let's solve a few equations.
I know you will see these equations
require more steps (ALGORITHM),
from the hitherto decided ones.
Fun in the equations is that there are more than one
a true way of solving.
As long as you do the right steps, that means
whatever you do on the left side, the same
to do right, and then there is no way to go wrong.
And you will get the right answer.
Let's solve a few equations.
The first equation: 1,3x - 0,7x = 12.
(one whole and three by X minus zero and seven by x equals 12).
The first thing that instinct tells us to do,
is to tie those two members together.
We have 1.3 something less minus 0.7 on the same thing.
This is the same variable.
For example, if we have 1.3 apples minus 0.7 of the same apples,
we can get 1.3 out of 0.7.
The X is the same, so we can export it as a TOTAL GENERATOR.
-> 1.3x - 0.7x = x (1.3 - 0.7)
This is equal to 12. The left hand is equal to the right.
As we have already said, we have brought out a TOTAL GENERATOR
before brackets.
And we did it for X.
X is an unknown number. We call it PARAMETER or UNKNOWN.
When a number such as 0.7 multiplies by one variable,
they become literally inseparable until they remain alone on one side of the equal.
1.3 by the variable x minus 0.7 by x is equal to 0.6 by x.
0.6x = 12
We have transformed the task to an easier level. We know how to solve this type of task
from other video lessons.
We have a number (coefficient) X (variable) equal to a number.
Let us divide the two sides of the equation of the number multiplied by X,
of the COEFFICIENT.
Divide to 0.6 (zero and six).
It's like SUCCESSING at the RECIPRONAL number of 0.6, which is 1 / 0.6.
On the left, 0.6 divided by 0.6 is 1. Only X remains.
X equals 12 divided by 0.6.
To make the division of 12 divided by 0.6 easier,
we multiply both numbers by 10.
12 by 10 is 120.
0.6 by 10 is 6.
It turned out that 120 divided into 6.
We know that 12 divided by 6 is 2.
So 120 divided by 6 is 20.
12 divided by 0.6 equals 20.
X equals 20.
And we can check the task.
Replace X with 20.
1.3 by 20 minus 0.7 on 20 left
is equal to 12 on the right.
Here's the calculator so we do not rely on
my calculus abilities.
1.3 by 20 is equal to 26.
We record 26 ...
And 0.7 by 20 ...
There is no need to consider it with a calculator, it's easy,
It is equal to 14.
26 minus 14 is 12. (26 - 14 = 12)
And here it is.
We have the left side equal to the right.
X equals 20.
Let's solve the next equation.
5x - (3x + 2) = 1 (5X minus in brackets 3X plus 2, closing brackets equals 1)
This seems very difficult.
When something seems very difficult to you, just follow the ALGORITHM (successive steps)
and you will gradually make the equation easier.
Over time, repeating the steps (algorithm)
you will see progress in yourself.
The first thing we will do is to uncover the brackets.
We have a minus in front of brackets.
We multiply each of the numbers in brackets by -1.
No?
5x minus ... 3x by -1 and 2 by -1 We get -3x and -2.
We multiplied each of the numbers in brackets by minus 1.
And -3x-2 was obtained.
5x -3x - 2 on the left
is equal to 1 on the right.
We have 5 x x minus 3 x,
5 from something minus 3 of the same thing
will be 2 of this thing.
5x minus 3x is 2x.
Because 5 minus 3 is 2.
The equation now looks like this: 2x - 2 = 1
The next step is to leave 2x only on the left side of the equation.
To do this, we need to get rid of -2.
So we add on both sides
of the equation +2.
Add plus 2
and to the left and right.
Because the left side should always be equal to the right side.
And if we do some action on the left, we have to do the same
and on the right.
Add +2 and right.
Left -2 and +2 are destroyed (because they are the same numbers but opposite characters).
And we got: 2x is equal to 1 plus 2, which is 3.
(2x = 1 + 2 .-> 2x = 3)
To remove the COEFFICIENT before x, divide the two sides of the equation to 2.
We get that x = 3/2
I'll leave your check on you to make sure that
this is the right answer.
Here I will a bit embrace the previous task,
so we do not go wrong.
In the next equation we have to find S.
As you can see, we have a liver and two members with S.
How will we solve this equation?
Just like others.
S minus 3/8 on S equals 5/6.
S - 3 / 8S = 5/6
We export S as TOTAL MULTIPLE TO SCOB.
S (1- 3/8) = 5/6
For both members, S repeats, so we can
we bring it out before brackets, and inside it is 1 because we have it
one S minus 3/8.
1 minus 3/8, how much is that?
This 1 can be represented as 8/8. Why exactly 8/8? Because the other number is 3/8 with a denominator 8, and it is easier to draw another number with the same denominator. If there is any other number, we will have to mislead a COMMON DIMMER and so on.
Which is 1. ANY NUMBER OF SECONDLY DIVIDED BY YOU 1.
Vadim 3/8 of 8/8 and gets 5/8. (8/8 - 3/8 = 5/8.)
We may reverse the order of multiplication.
5/8 by equal to 5/6.
From here we can immediately determine s.
If we have 1 of the parameter s minus 3/8 of s, we get
8/8 of s minus 3/8 of this.
The result is 5/8 per s.
Second, to find s, we must multiply both sides by
Reciprocal value of 5/8, which is 8/5.
We multiply from left to 8/5. 8/5 in 5 / 8s.
What we do on the left side of the equation, the same we do
and on the right side of the equation.
Right to 8/5.
Left 8/5 and 5/8 are destroyed
and only s remains.
And on the right 5 in the numerator it is shortened by 5 in the denominator.
8 and 6 we can divide them into 2.
We divide in NUMBER 8 to 2, which is 4.
And divide 6 in the TIMER at 2,
which gives 3.
Four on Three remain.
4/3
S equals 4/3 (S = 4/3).
Let's do one more.
Here I have 5q minus 7 on 12 is equal to 2/3.
Let's write it.
Or we can write it like 5/12 in (q - 7)
is equal to 2/3.
And in this lesson I want to show you,
that we can act in two ways.
Of course, while we act as we are, we will receive
the same answer.
The first way we do it is
by multiplying both sides of the equation by
reciprocal on 5/12.
Ie. I will multiply both sides by 12 on 5.
Because I want to remove this 5/12
on the left side.
It only hinders us in this case.
We will multiply it by 12 on 5, because it will
remove.
5 and 5 are abbreviated and 12 and 12 are abbreviated.
So the left side of the equation becomes Q minus 7,
equal to the right side, 2/3 at 5/12.
If you divide 12 to 3, you get 4.
Divide 3 to 3 you get 1.
And 2 in 4 is equal to 8 on 5.
And now we can add 7 to both sides of this equation.
Let's do it - but let it be in another color.
Add 7 to both sides.
These weeks are getting shorter.
That was our point, adding 7.
And we stay with q = 8/5 plus 7.
Or we can write 7 as 35/5.
And this will be equal to 8,
the denominator is 5,
8 plus 35 is 43.
The decision, in this line of thought, is q = 43/5.
I said we would do it in two ways.
Let's try the other.
Let's write the same task.
We have 5/12 ... in fact, let's solve the problem
in a radically different way.
Let's write it as it is in the condition.
5 (q - 7) / 12 = 2/3.
Let's remove 12 first. Let's multiply both sides
of the equation of 12.
I just do not like this 12 here, that's why
we will multiply by 12.
So these will catch up and we will stay
with 5 (q - 7) = 2/3 by 12.
This is the same as 24 on 3.
Let's write it.
2/3 at 12/1 is equal ... if you divide it at 3,
you get 4, divide this at 3
and we get 1 equal to 8.
Ie. we have 5 (q - 7) equals 8.
And then instead of dividing the sides to 5, which will help us a lot
to achieve what we need here,
let's reveal the brackets and multiply it by 5,
you can multiply in different ways.
5 in q is 5q.
5 at -7 is -35, equals 8.
5q - 35 is equal to 8.
To eliminate this -35, the best
The way we do it is like
add 35 to both sides.
We do this to catch up with these, and we stay with
5q equal to 8 + 35, which is 43.
Now we can multiply both sides by 1/5,
which is the same as dividing the sides into 5.
And these are getting shorter.
We have q equal to 43 on 5.
You see there are many ways to handle these tasks.
As long as you do it properly, you will receive it
the right answer always.
I'll let you check if that's true
is the answer to q.
When we find q, we've decided the equation.
Now let's solve a textual problem.
Jade is alone in town and has only 10 leva to get to his home.
The taxi costs 0.75 leva per kilometer, but there is an initial fee of 2.35 leva.
Display a formula and use it to figure out how many kilometers
the girl will go by the money she has.
So ...
The entire taxi will be equal to
the initial fee is 2.35 leva +
BGN 0.75 per kilometer, multiplied by kilometers.
Let me be equal to the kilometers traveled.
The kilometers traveled.
And this is our equation.
We know she has only 10 leva to get home.
Ie. the price must be 10.
We have already said that the price should be 10 leva.
10 is equal to 2.35 + 0.75m.
How to find m, or the amount of miles,
who can travel?
We can remove 2.35 on the right,
by pulling it out on both sides
of this equation.
Let's do it.
We take out 2.35 on both sides.
These are destroyed.
That's what we want.
On the left - how much is 10 minus 2.35?
These are destroyed.
And now, how much is 10 minus 2.35?
10 minus 2 is 8.
10 minus 2.3 is 7.7.
Ie. equal to 7.65.
You may believe me, but let's check it out.
10 minus 2.35
is 7.65.
And that will be 0.75 kilometers.
Let's write it in the same color.
It's good to see where things come from.
0.75 kilometers.
I have 5 shades of purple.
Here, here and these two
are destroyed.
Now find m. We can just divide to 0.75.
If we divide one side to 0.75,
you know, we have to separate the other
to 0.75.
This is getting shorter and so on the right we stay
only with m.
And on the left ... let me take the sack
for this part ...
We have 7.65 divided by 0.75, which is
equal to 10.2.
Or Jade can travel 10.2 kilometers.